peter
bogosian taught philosophy at portland
state university for the past decade
he just wrote a public letter to the
university's provost announcing he's
quitting you can read the whole thing on
sub stack and you should
here's a part of it quote
this university has transformed a
bastion of free inquiry into a social
justice factory his only inputs for race
gender and victimhood and whose only
outputs were grievance and division
peter bogosian is the author of how to
have impossible conversations
it's a great great
title of a book almost as good as how i
saved the world
and he joins us here
all right professor
explain how this professor ex-professor
as of a couple hours ago
how did this all go down
well the university basically created
conditions that didn't allow me to teach
what i was hired to do which was
critical thinking and and ethics
and so i could not retain
my current position as is
so you're saying that you were doing
what you've always done teach critical
thinking assign reading materials of
famous philosophers and encouraging
robust debate and conversation and that
was impossible because of what precisely
well the university told me i wasn't
allowed to render my opinion about
protected classes or teach in any way
that my opinion about protected classes
could be known the university
really
made it difficult in terms of students
were telling me that other professors
had told them not to take my class
there were flyers around me with campus
around campus with a
pinocchio nose but this isn't really
about necessarily the things that
happened to me that's just a piece of
the larger picture of the social justice
ecosystem that's taken over our
university system well describe that
ecosystem describe for people who didn't
experience that in college i did not
experience that at all i was actually a
philosophy major
for two years until i read kant
and i couldn't stand the guy i'm sure
you agree
and switch to history
but
what kind of things are professors like
yourself experiencing where they're
unable to do their jobs
they're experiencing anyone who speaks
out against the dominant moral orthodoxy
particularly with regard to race gender
or sexual orientation trans issues for
example
let me just give you a quick example in
ethics one of the issues that we're
facing today as a society are trans
issues trans bathrooms would be an
example of that or trans women in sports
trans men in sports and what that means
and
the trans is a protected class and so i
wasn't allowed to
speak about protected classes among
other things so there was a
sensoriousness about the university and
there was always always the threat of
investigation i was investigated so many
times for so many things and the total
results of the investigation were nada
zilch they found nothing but they
weaponized offices of diversity equity
and inclusion and even the threat of
going to
be called in for a theft of your time
and if nothing else the investigators
are incredibly thorough so they have
these mechanisms in place in the
university to enforce certain speech
codes against professors against
dissident professors against anyone who
questions or challenges what's morally
fashionable
so they actually employ little social
justice warriors
within departments
to keep tabs on professors that are
deemed controversial
they weren't controversial maybe 10
years ago but now because everything's
gone nuts are controversial they
threaten investigations or they do do
they investigate microaggressions is
that something that they're looking into
you can't even define many times by the
way
right so it's a small slight usually
against race or or gender or some kind
of perceived status like ability status
one of the things they don't have an
office for investigating
microaggressions but among the things
that i was
brought up on charges someone asked me
if race was a social construct or a
biological category and i said i don't
know i'm a philosopher i'm not a
biologist and among other things i was
brought in upon i was brought on in
charge of that i've been accused of of a
microaggression when i asked for the
evidence for microaggressions i've been
accused of microaggressions when i asked
by colleagues and by students
when i asked for evidence of the
policies that were engulfing like
trigger warnings why should there be a
trigger warning on a syllabus what is
the evidence that safe spaces are
helpful to students
so those things themselves even asking
for evidence was a microaggression so
you've created a kind of a culture in
which even asking questions about things
is viewed as a violation
it's a it's become a dogma factory
that's astounding humility is now
a chargeable offense saying i don't know
that's not my area of expertise they can
they can bring you up on charges of
microaggression
well i'm sorry to hear that and it looks
like it's destroying
rational discourse in our universities
which is the point of universities to
explore to ask questions to understand
opposing opinions you can't do that
anymore you can't ask questions you just
have to go along with the dogma and if
you don't
you're in trouble
right and having conversations is
impossible having robust debates about
certain topics is impossible and so
think about the injustice we're doing to
our students when we're creating these
large ecosystems that don't allow that
they don't allow questioning they don't
allow challenging and so students are
particularly brittle when they hear the
other side of a debate i believe very
strongly as john stuart mill did that we
have to be taught by people
who actually believe things i believe
there should be a marxist in an
economics department i believe that
there should be a friedmanite in an
economics department i believe that
there should be intellectual diversity
and we give students the tools to figure
out these issues and ask difficult
questions and we're not doing that
all right peter just don't ask about the
vaccine
that's way way way too dangerous
thank you jessie i appreciate having me
on all right hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else